Das ist
das versprochene Q&A zum Impfen.
Wir gehen auf die Fragen ein, die ihr
extrem zahlreich gestellt habt.
Danke für die Rückmeldungen
und die aktive
und angeregte Diskussion.
Wir mussten ein paar Fragen
bzw. Bemerkungen löschen,
die gegen unsere Netiquette
verstiessen.
Die Mehrheit wurde aber publiziert.
Cool, dass das funktioniert hat.
Jetzt zu euren Fragen.
"Es ist keine Impfung", sagt Sonja.
"Wieso wird immer
von Impfung gesprochen?"
Es seien Gentherapien, sagt Sonja.
Dazu nur kurz: Sonja,
es ist ein genbasierter Impfstoff.
Und der gelangt -
laut heutigem Wissensstand
und den Informationen
beim Bundesamt für Gesundheit,
die man auf deren Internetseite
nachlesen kann -
nicht in den Zellkern, kann also das
menschliche Erbgut nicht verändern.
Das zu dieser Info
resp. deiner Feststellung.
Dann: "Im Video sah man
einen Impfstofftransport
in einem Camping-Kühlkompressor",
schreibt Arben und fragt,
was das solle.
Hochprofessionell, wie es
in der Schweiz zu und her gehe.
Dazu kann man sagen:
Wir haben es im Film gehört -
den Impfstoff müsse man bei -4 °C
kühlen, sagt der Arzt Supersaxo.
Das ist der Impfstoff,
der ursprünglich bei über -70 °C
transportiert werden musste
und bei dem ein paar Tage
bei -4 °C ...
... Kühlung ausreichend sind.
Ich sage: Das ist die Schweiz,
da reicht eine solche Camping...
Da reicht
eine Campingbox zur Kühlung.
Die Kühlkette muss eingehalten
werden, das ist entscheidend.
Die Person, die das geschrieben hat,
sagt:
Sie fand den Film gut,
aber noch spannender wäre es gewesen,
wenn Junge mit dabei gewesen wären.
Das hätten wir uns auch gewünscht.
Wir versuchten,
sie mittels Umfragen einzubinden.
Momentan werden aber ältere
und vulnerable Menschen geimpft.
Insofern sind Junge
noch weit weg von diesem Impfstoff.
Deshalb wäre es bei ihnen
eher darum gegangen,
ob sie dann würden, wenn ...
Wir suchten z.B. eine junge Person,
die mit ihren Grosseltern
die Diskussion führt,
ob sie sich impfen lassen oder nicht.
Am Schluss sagten aber
alle angefragten Personen ab,
ein solches innerfamiliäres Gespräch
zum Impfen zu führen.
Wir bemühten uns also und
hätten auch gerne mehr Junge gezeigt.
Aber für diesen Film
hat es nicht gereicht.
Dann sagt jemand, es sei logisch,
dass der Arzt für die Impfung sei
und wieso man ihn dies
überhaupt frage.
Man frage ja auch keinen Autover-
käufer, ob er Autofahren gut finde.
Ich erinnere mich nicht daran,
den Arzt gefragt zu haben,
ob er für oder gegen die Impfung sei,
sondern er kam am Schluss -
als er in der Argumentation
vorbrachte,
weshalb er diesen Impfstoff
als gut und sicher einstufe -
vermutlich zu dieser Antwort.
Explizit gefragt
habe ich ihn dies aber nicht,
denn es wäre tatsächlich
etwas absurd,
dies einen Impfarzt zu fragen.
Noch etwas zum Arzt.
Eine Person
unter dem Namen hold on schreibt,
dass Dr. Supersaxo lüge.
Und zwar habe er fadenscheinig
geantwortet auf die Frage,
weshalb er die ältere Person bezüg-
lich Nebenwirkungen nicht aufklärte.
Da muss man etwas
zum Hintergrund dieses Films sagen.
Ich würde nicht
so weit gehen zu sagen,
dass der Arzt Supersaxo lügt -
überhaupt nicht, sondern:
Wir meldeten uns bei der Gesund-
heitsdirektion des Kantons Bern
und fragten an,
ob wir bei ihnen filmen können.
An diesem Morgen war
das Team vor Ort, das wir antrafen.
Wir hatten zuvor
nicht miteinander gesprochen.
Herr Supersaxo wusste nicht,
was auf ihn zukommt.
Er wusste, dass wir filmen, aber ob
und welche Fragen wir stellen würden,
wollte er nicht wissen.
Auch im Nachhinein sagte er nichts.
Er sagte also nicht: "Ihr habt mich
überrumpelt und Sachen gefragt,
auf die ich so
nicht vorbereitet war."
Das hat er alles nicht gemacht.
Er hat, im Gegenteil, sehr ...
... geduldig und unkompliziert
unsere Fragen beantwortet.
Insofern finde ich eher,
dass er in seinen Aussagen
sehr ehrlich und authentisch war.
Das ist meine Antwort
auf die Feststellung
der Person hold on.
Gut.
Dann gab es
ein paar Fragen zur Moderation.
Markus fragt resp. stellt fest,
dass er den Film gut fand,
aber er sei der Meinung,
die Moderatorin, also ich,
habe ihre eigene Meinung
zu sehr in den Vordergrund gestellt.
Dass ich also
meinungsbildend gewesen sei.
Das nehme ich zur Kenntnis, Markus,
obwohl dies keinesfalls die Idee war.
Ich wollte möglichst wertneutral
jene Fragen aufnehmen und stellen,
die die Gegenseite habe könnte.
Insofern wollte ich eher
ein Transportmittel für Meinungen
und Aussagen der anderen Seite sein.
Es war nicht gewollt,
dass ich im Vordergrund stehe.
Insofern -
auch wenn es bei dir so ankam,
Absicht war es nicht.
Dann zur Unabhängigkeit
und Neutralität.
Andrea schreibt,
dass wir bei diesen
zusammengeschnittenen Umfragen
sicher nicht unabhängig seien,
denn wir hätten
bei der Aussage,
es sei eine grössere Macht,
die das zusammenhalte,
hinterhergeschickt,
dass es überall Spinner gebe.
Wer hier nicht kapiere,
dass wir nicht unabhängig seien ...
Dazu sage ich, Andrea:
Selbstverständlich
haben wir das zusammengeschnitten.
Und zwar deshalb, weil es
bei Umfragen ja immer darum geht,
eine Sinneinheit zu bilden, die
als Dialog hätte stattfinden können.
Es ergibt also Sinn, dass
die Person im Anschluss dies so sagt.
Es hätte auch jemand sagen können,
dass es genau richtig ist,
was er sagt - das hatten wir so aber
nicht, deshalb dieser Ausschnitt.
Es ist
jedem und jeder selbst überlassen,
welcher Meinung
er oder sie beipflichten will.
Insofern:
Es war ein sinnhafter Dialog,
den wir zusammengesetzt haben.
Aber wertend ...
... war auch gar nicht die Idee.
Dann die Frage von Fluxlol,
warum die ...
... Impfvorteile diskutiert würden,
wenn die Impfpflicht nur eine
Verschwörungstheorie gewesen sei.
Da frage ich zurück:
Wer sagt, dass es
nur eine Verschwörungstheorie war?
Seit die COVID-19-Impfung
im Raum steht und existiert,
geht es um das Thema,
dass es vielleicht an gewissen Orten
Impfobligatorien geben wird,
auch wenn es zurzeit laut Epidemien-
gesetz kein Obligatorium gibt.
D.h., Bundesrat und Kantone
haben es nicht in Kraft gesetzt.
Das ist der momentane Stand, aber:
Dass dies womöglich ändert,
dass auf privater Basis
Pflichten eingeführt werden,
das ist meines Wissens, seit es
diese Impfung gibt, ein Thema.
Zum Schluss zum Technischen.
Dazu gibt es ein paar Fragen.
Eine technische Frage ist,
weshalb wir bei Min. 22 eine Stimme
doppelt nachgesprochen haben.
Wir haben diese Stimme
nicht doppelt nachgesprochen,
sondern wir nutzten die Stimme der
Person, die anonym bleiben wollte,
als Basis
und haben diese leicht verfremdet.
Eine Sprecherin
sprach dann über diese Stimme drüber.
Dies sei sehr anstrengend
zum Zuhören, schreibt asterod.
Das kann ich verstehen,
danke für den Hinweis.
Wir glaubten, mit dieser Stimme eine
gewisse Authentizität zu schaffen.
Aber vielleicht war es zu verwirrend.
Nochmals etwas Technisches.
MohaMett fragt, warum es so abartig
schlecht gefilmt gewesen sei
oder ob das Kunst sein solle.
Dazu sage ich: weder noch.
Ich finde nicht,
dass es schlecht gefilmt war,
aber das ist Geschmackssache.
Kunst soll es ebenfalls nicht sein,
das Ziel war eine Reportage.
D.h., man filmt, was kommt.
Man schaut nicht zuerst,
dass das Bild perfekt ist.
Dort kann es
selbstverständlich passieren,
dass Bilder reinrutschen, die ...
... in deinen oder gewissen Augen
nicht so toll sind,
aber das Ganze
inhaltlich vorantreiben.
Insofern ist das ein Teil des Ganzen.
Aber ja,
man kann dieser Meinung sein.
Es gibt bestimmt Dinge, die man
ein andermal optimieren könnte.
Es ist aber nicht so,
dass wir es kunstvoll oder
besonders schlecht machen wollten.